Mark's with us in Fort Lauderdale hey
Mark welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up um if you're fiscally
responsible why are you so against using
credit cards what would be wrong with
using a debit card well if you're
physically like dull I I travel a lot uh
so do i and credit cards make it easier
I know that you can do rental cars and
hotels without credit cards but you can
do my typical
I feel that credit cards are so I feel
the credit cards are safer than debit
cards why do you feel that one because
I'm only responsible for fifty dollars
on a credit card if somebody that's not
true if somebody steals your credit card
number and uses it fraudulently you're
responsible for zero even better yeah
and guess what you're responsible for on
your debit card if they steal it use it
zero but then you have to fight with
them to get it back no no you just call
your bank and they call your bank and
they put the money back and then they go
through the dispute procedure to see
that it was a fraudulent use by the way
you have to go through a dispute
procedure to see that it was a
fraudulent use as well with your credit
card and if they rule against you in
either case you've lost the money but if
it was a legitimate legitimate fraud
that sounds backwards but if it was
really a fraud in neither case do you
lose money that's the facts well well if
they're pretty much the same then and
you pay them off monthly so what do you
have against 100% of debit cards do not
have debt on them and most people do not
pay off their credit cards like 58
million people last month did not pay
theirs off just to kind of give an idea
and I know that I know I know you said
you said fiscally responsible but here's
the thing why are we playing with snakes
what's the point why are we playing with
something that might hurt us when the
other tool works just as well well I I
do use some of the advantages from
credit cards uh warioland client card
gives you two to three nights in a year
now hotel realm and yes it does cost $75
a year but thirty five dollars a night
and you know Hyatt in Boston is way more
than $35 a night but I'm not saying
that's all the advantages but I do use
those advantages and what do you make a
year uh just under two hundred thousand
and we're having a discussion about two
hundred bucks
well I see this is your motivator at me
really
that's smart logical but I mean I I pay
off my credit cards monthly I know hey
so you don't you don't have to worry
about that if it's a debit card because
you had to have the money before you
bought it so that's why I'm against it
you asked I have a feeling this far into
the conversation I'm probably not going
to talk you into it and that's fine
because I don't think you're going to go
bankrupt because of it mark but here's
the thing I just decided a long time ago
I'm not going to play with snakes
because they bite I work with credit
card companies and our firm does every
day and I know what scum they are and I
know what problems they present and I
know what all the crap that comes around
when stuff doesn't get paid and the
billing cycles that they change and they
move something by four days on when they
decide to post your check so they can
back charge you through the whole month
for the interest and then you got to go
fight with them over all that all of
this so you can get a $35 hotel room
when you make $200,000 a year and you
pay it off anyway so you should have
been using a debit card to start with on
top of all of that I use cash for a lot
of things because there's tons of
studies that show that when you actually
spend cash you spend twelve to eighteen
percent less than you do when using
plastic now the debit card falls prey to
that problem as well because you don't
you don't feel emotionally feel the pain
centers of the brain aren't active a
when you spend with plastic I experience
this mark as an example we were on
property with Disney a while back
wonderful vacation with the kids and
they turn your room key into your debit
card for the week and so you can you
know you can walk around your room key
and it all charges
all charges back to the room and I teach
this crap for a living and I catch
myself buying $18 ice cream cones and
not thinking anything about it I'm going
cried man I just finance my kids college
education with an ice cream cone here
and so you know it's just you don't you
don't register the pain you know vending
machines you travel like I do if you
notice all the vending machines and I'll
take credit cards a hundred and seventy
eight percent increase in sales when
they take plastic over cash because
people don't feel the pain with cash or
with the plastic that they do when they
use cash so all of that weaves into this
is this money thing is a behavior thing
it's not just a transaction and so
you've got to manage your behaviors in
such a way that it leads you to be
wealthy now mark you make $200,000 a
year
I truly believe you when you say you're
fiscally responsible and pay your card
off every month so I am not suggesting
you're going to go bankrupt I am
suggesting you playing around the edges
of something and really you're majoring
in minors to get a few dollars back here
or there and you're losing the argument
so I mean if you want to if you want to
do it it's okay
I'm not only mad at you you know it's
going to be friends it's okay
but my suggestion is not I don't have a
credit card and I travel as much or
maybe more than you do mark and so do
all the stuff you do and debit card I
really don't run into problems with my
debit card it does everything I need to
do and and I don't run into a bunch of
fraudulent transactions I don't run into
a big hassles or anything else and so
forth but I use a lot of cash to even on
the road I use cash and and because it
keeps me in check and again I'm the guy
that teaches this stuff and so if
anybody's not susceptible to it since I
have the intellectual knowledge of this
stuff it would be me but even I know
that I'm going to fall for this crap
that is their world and is their
business I am almost positive mark and
it's one of my missions as a matter of
fact that we're going to look back 20
years from now and we're going to say
the credit card was the cigarette of the
financial world when we were kids it was
cool and everybody smoked them on the
movies and everything else now if you
smoke everybody kind of looks at you
like you're an idiot and and pretty much
you're treated that way everywhere you
go and that's where the credit card is
going to end up because it's going to be
so discredited no pun intended as a
viable tool again you make enough money
you're you're in good shape you're
disciplined guy it's not going to kill
you but you ask why I am against it
that's why this is the Dave Ramsey show